a string of high-end smash and grabs has
retailers on edge as shoppers hit the
stores for christmas one retailer is
spending 30 000
a month on private security but it's the
local stores already pinched by the
pandemic that may get hardest hit anita
when you have a mob of people like those
that busted into that la nordstroms
spraying the guard with bear spray
stealing 25 000 worth of goods how can a
guard be expected to stop them but my
question is
what do the small mom and pop stores do
yeah they they can't they can't pay
thirty thousand dollars a month for
security i mean that particular store
that did that is a very high-end electro
electronics chain that's backed by
venture capital companies and that's why
they're able to pay 30 grand a month for
security you know you can't have guards
overrun by you know 80 people coming
into the store with pepper spray and who
knows what else they just they can't i
mean i saw you know one mall in santa
monica was putting up barbed wire
outside i mean maybe that will help but
really what places like california need
are better laws you know in california
they have something called proposition
47 that reduced felonies like
shoplifting to misdemeanors and so
nobody's spending any time in prison for
these for these crimes anymore right
tyra says i need to mention that prop 47
passed in california it actually forbids
prosecuting nonviolent offenders who
steal under 950 bucks worth of
merchandise this is governor gavin
newsom listen
i'm not the mayor of california
but i was a mayor
and i know when things like this happen
mayors have to step up we want real
accountability we want people prosecuted
and we want people to feel safe this
holiday season
tyrus your reaction is it the local
mayor's fault in these cases out in
california
well did you not hear that i mean
boys and girls at home that's how you
pass the buck that's a good way of
passing it down because there's nothing
a governor can do
to possibly help this
what is basically organized crime now uh
you know and the here's the sad reality
small business owners no they're not
going to be able to survive this they
could barely survive the the stuff that
was put on by this administration in
terms of having to raise everyone's pay
to at least 15 an hour have to pay
certain insurances have to have to deal
with all kinds of issues with employees
and not being able to get people then
you have you can't get anything on the
shelf so once you get robbed and wiped
out you're not going to get anything
back because the they're not being
prosecuted even worse your police
department is depleted scared to make an
arrest without someone trying to say
that they're racist or brutality so
they're just sitting ducks and these
groups are getting bolder they're now
literally
80 people got together how do you think
they did they got that on their facebook
or their instagram and they're planning
stuff because they know this is this is
a dangerous time to own a shop and then
we're going to see more vigilante
situations where uh someone's going to
be charged and attacked by mainstream
media for trying to defend his family
and his company and you know because we
just they run the dinner bell
i don't think the unaffected really have
a problem with this this isn't going to
be a problem until gavin walks into his
mansion and sees it's been emptied out
and robbed by 150 looters then he'll
care then it will be an issue but in the
meantime he it's it's not it's not his
fault they're just fighting back for the
all the horrible things that the
previous administration did for them
this is this is their fault this is
president trump's fault
individuals doing it
and tyrus these flash mobs you talk
about you know these organized gangs
many of them are juveniles and that's
intentional and i read a statistic 30
billion dollars a year is what retailers
lose in merchandise stolen merchandise
every year a friend of mine that works
with walmart told me they work into
their budget that one walmart store will
be entirely taken away from them
nationally in merchandise that's
incredible lara i want your reviews you
can do that go ahead
yeah but but mom and pops shops can't
yep they get wiped out they're done
right and then they'll start and i saw
that
when i interviewed some of those folks
lara i want your reaction to this story
out of raleigh north carolina there was
a shootout in the mall the other day
three were injured including a
ten-year-old uh i always say if you
don't have safety you can't have
prosperity this is surely going to scare
shoppers lara but isn't this again
a law enforcement and a prosecution
problem
yeah well i went to school in raleigh
north carolina i went to north carolina
state university we did beat carolina
yesterday in football i'm just going to
point that out throw it out there for
everybody um not a big deal but no look
you're you're so right raymond without
safety and security nothing else matters
you know you see what happened in
waukesha wisconsin you know at a
christmas parade people want to get out
and they want to celebrate the season by
shopping and going out with their
families to the mall and you know we are
in a time right now where so many of the
issues come from democrat-run cities and
democrat-run states and if you have da's
that are not willing to uh you know
prosecute people if you have mayors that
are allowing these criminals to just get
away with any and everything then why
wouldn't they try and do it even the
smallest offense is an issue because it
only incentivizes people to continue to
do that sort of thing it's basic human
nature and so look as a mom i want to
feel safe taking my kids to the mall i
want to feel safe taking my kids to a
parade and of course now that we have
these underfunded police departments we
know that police police officers are
retiring at record levels especially in
our metropolitan cities all across
america it is not helping the problem it
is of course only making it worse and
you absolutely hate to see it this
should be a time of year at least where
you feel safe taking your kids out to do
something fun
well i love chaser bodine who's the the
d.a in san francisco he's prosecuting
nine people 20 to 40 were videotaped
smashing windows in that store so good
job chase we'll leave it there hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else